is the Bugatti Chiron the world's
fastest car that's the world's fastest
car lagging behind Tesla's latest sedan
out of five races this Tesla plaid won
four four let that sink in so how is
this possible how has Tesla created a
sedan that can outpace a Supercar
Tesla's incredible engine vehicles are
only as powerful as their engine the
Tesla plaid is no different and its
engine can be found where most if not
all other EV engines are often found on
its floor this floor is known as the
powertrain think of it as an electric
vehicle's motherboard both the batteries
and the motors can be found here unlike
all other Tesla models before it and
other EVS the plaid's powertrain has
three new carbon wrap Motors but more on
that in a second the motors are easily
the most important part of an EV in the
model S plaid it's carbon wrapped Motors
are the primary reason why it is capable
of such ungodly Feats of acceleration
but hold on one second before we get
lost using terms that you might or might
not be familiar with if I think it's
important that we brush up on the basics
of what motors are first more
importantly how they make electric
vehicles work so we can truly appreciate
why this engine is marvelous electric
motors to create motion an electric
motor uses electromagnetism to convert
electrical energy into mechanical energy
the magnets within the electrical motor
can be divided into the rotor and the
stator the stator is a stationary curved
magnet that appears to act as a
protective shield around the other
magnet this other magnet is the rotor
and it isn't stationary when this rotor
is wrapped in a metallic coil it becomes
an electromagnet capable of switching
the charges or polarity of its end and
if you're familiar with how magnets
behave then you know that they repel and
attract depending on what charges are on
the end of either magnet now when this
electromagnetic rotor is placed on an
axis within a stator its polarity
interacts with the polarity of the rotor
and causes the latter to spin in the
world of EVS that spinning motion is
referred to as an RP PM also known as
revolutions per minute this serves as a
measurement for the number of rotations
the rotor makes in a minute which is
often directly linked with the speed of
the vehicle in question now the higher
the electrical current flowing into the
motor the higher the strength of the
electromagnetic field and the faster the
rotor can spin and the faster the RPM
that's how Motors work in a nutshell
it's a simplified version and I've
skimmed over a lot of things but don't
worry you won't get lost now let's talk
about the plaid's special carbon wrapped
motor for the longest time Tesla has
been bent on revamping the powertrain of
their lineup in the past the older Tesla
vehicles including the older model S
featured the dual motor however the new
plaid features a new tri-motor
powertrain which consists of a single
front motor and two Motors in the rear
the new powertrain is a marvelous feat
of engineering and it along with its
components was in no way easy to make
during the model S plaid delivery event
Elon Musk announced that the powertrain
featured new battery packs but to be
frank they aren't really new the
original plan was to use a structural
battery pack along with the framed 4680
batteries that Tesla has planned for
years to manufacture with the help of
Panasonic these batteries would have
worked with all the other parts of the
powertrain to achieve the insane
performance that the Plaid currently
features but the year 2020 happened the
pandemic choked Supply chains and the
pressure for production of the Plaid
reached such feverish Heights that Tesla
was forced to recall and repurpose the
1865 cell that was used in the original
Roadster somehow they made it work
however beyond the battery cell one of
the more impressive achievements on the
powertrain of Model S plaid has to be
its Motors since the Plaid Model S
functions on what you could call a
single speed gearbox and because this
cancels any gear reductions the motors
operate at very high speeds and can
reach up to 20 000 RPM or more this
incredibly fast motor rotation allows
the Tesla to move from zero to 200 miles
on a single speed and even more
impressively it can mean maintain those
top speeds for extended periods but this
brings up more questions we know that
high rotational speeds cause the rotor
to expand and that the centrifugal force
from those levels of rotation should
easily unravel the coils on the rotor
rendering the vehicle useless or Worse
dangerous Elon Musk had an answer to
this and then something we're really
proud of is the new carbon-sleeved
rotors for the motor so this is the
first time that the best of our
knowledge has been a production electric
motor that have that has a carbon over
app rotor this is a super hard thing to
do because a carbon and copper have at
very different rates of thermal
expansions so taking what Elon said the
three rotors within the motors of the
plaid's powertrain are carbon wrapped
remember when I said that wrapping coils
around a rotor turns them into
electromagnets well Elon says that they
had to design a machine that wrapped the
carbon on the Rotor at extremely high
tensions which according to him was
incredibly hard but also according to
him created an electromagnetic field
that was extremely efficient carbon
fiber is a very durable material it is
five times as strong as steel and has a
much lower rate of thermal expansion so
it will remain constant even when the
temperatures shoot to the roof but this
raises yet another problem that we have
skimmed over so far the carbon wrapping
is good for keeping the rotor in place
but it does nothing to mitigate the Heat
and when a rotor is rotating at 20 000
RPMs you can bet there will be a lot of
heat thankfully the Tesla team was way
ahead of us in mitigating this issue
there's hardly anything that directly
impacts the performance of a vehicle's
engine than overheating and to achieve
Peak condition there has to be a proper
thermal management system within that
vehicle both the motors and the battery
pack have to remain cool in the first
generation of the Tesla Model S and
after just a few quarter mile runs the
vehicle's power would be drastically
throttled down to protect its battery
and motors from overheating however
every iteration of the model S leading
up to the Plaid has seen improvements in
its thermal management system we also
have the latest and greatest in heat
pump which is the basically the HVAC
system for the car it's 30 better cold
weather range and requires 50 less
energy for cabin Heating and freezing
conditions yeah so it's you'll see very
little degradation in cold weather Elon
also speaks about the radiator which is
two times as big as its previous
iterations and he also says that it's
one of the defining factors why the
Plaid can go from 0 to 60 over and over
again without burning up now I might
have hinted at it at the beginning of
this video but I think it's time we
properly addressed it just how fast is
the Tesla plaid Model S I mean is it an
insane engine if it doesn't give the car
insane speed understanding the
impressive speed of the Plaid requires a
quick trip down Tesla's past we need to
First compare this Beast to its previous
iterations June 2012 after years of
waiting the original model S is finally
released and to the Delight of Tesla
customers the world over it is a twin
motor all-wheel luxury vehicle capable
of moving from 0 to 60 mph in 4 0.2
seconds that kind of speed wasn't meant
to be found on an EV in 2012. so driving
a Model S at the time was not too
different from fighting in the American
Civil War with nuclear weapons but Tesla
wasn't done not yet they began dishing
out upgrades with the enthusiasm of a
granny spoiling her favorite nephew on
Thanksgiving by 2015 car enthusiasts
were so impressed with the upgrades that
Business Insider released this article
where they formed endlessly over the
already impressive Model S and you can't
blame them one of the upgrades called
the Insane Mode push the model S down
from 4.2 seconds for the naught to 60
second Sprint to 3.8 seconds the next
major upgrade called the ludicrous mode
pushed the time down further to an
unbelievable 2.8 seconds shattering the
three-second barrier and entering with
all four wheels into Supercar territory
this was the kind of speed you only
found with Classics like Ferrari
LaFerrari and the McLaren P1 both of
which cost over a million bucks in
contrast that version of the Model S
went for just one hundred thousand
dollars today the latest model S the
Plaid does 0 to 60 in 1.88 seconds way
faster than the Bugatti Chiron and
possibly way faster than any other
supercar in the world today and don't
just take my word for it take the word
of professionals who put the Plaid
vehicle to the test professional race
car driver Randy popes drove the Plaid
on a Laguna Seca track the Tesla was
pitted against actual sports cars on the
track was the Porsche GT2 RS a McLaren
Senna and a McLaren P1 at first the
McLaren Center took the lead but the
Tesla quickly caught up and passed it
like it wasn't even moving an article
that documented the race mentioned
Pope's remarking that the model S plaid
which only had 34 charge remaining then
felt just as quick as it did when it
still had a full charge this means that
the Tesla pad will maintain high speed
over long distances with no power loss
even as the battery state decreases and
if you don't know I'll tell you the plan
is not Tesla Supercar that title belongs
to their other more exclusive offering
the Roadster the Plaid Model S is
Tesla's premium four-door sedan a family
vehicle made for luxurious practicality
it might move like a McLaren but it
won't turn heads like one sure it has an
impressive sound system and a
state-of-the-art infotainment system
with PS5 level computing power and sure
it will soon have full self-driving
capabilities when Tesla releases the
software updates but I must say it once
again the Plaid is not a sports car it
just has the engine of one
[Music]